there is a family some of you may have
heard of uh didi
tai hutu i think is how you say this
didi tai hutu uh and his wife plus three
kids they liquidated all of their assets
and bought bitcoin in 2017
when it was around 900
so early 2017 they do this this is a
family of uh this beautiful family
standing in front of uh something that i
don't know what that is uh and
they are dutch family what is it it's in
rome are you sure it's in rome yeah how
do you know
because that's the fountain i was the
one that found no i don't think that's
the fountain because the fountain no the
traverse fountain yeah exactly exactly
john tell them that ain't the fact that
anyone wants to fight
okay hold on let's just let's settle the
debate what is it the traverse
somebody said they're standing in front
of their house and somebody said you're
standing in front of a building
that is not the fountain tell us what it
is in the comments someone's got to know
someone tell us what it is i don't know
what that building is it's rome but what
is it no people are saying
they don't know that it's rome tell me
what the building is don't just tell me
it's wrong i know matt coyle said it's
rome i've seen it
i've been to rome i didn't see it so
then it's not rome it's right
they have the here military museum italy
yeah you can see the italian italian
flags okay do military museum italy joe
see if that's it use google lens
wedding cake whatever all right so this
family ended up selling all of their uh
goods other net worth they put it all in
bitcoin it's a dutch family of five uh
and they have secret vaults on four
different continents uh which is
interesting and didi taihutu uh he
played professional football until he
was 20. and after finishing school he
realized he didn't want to be an
employee so he started and sold three
successful businesses uh and then after
he sold his company he started to travel
with his family now this story uh is
getting picked up by all these different
outlets uh because people think it's
crazy that he sold all of his belongings
put it in bitcoin his family travels
around the world and they're kind of
like the bitcoin family what is more
interesting to me
is
the fact that
he's taking a approach to life that is
very different than most most people
spend majority of their waking hours
working trying to make money and then
their ideas that they're going to make
money for 40 or 50 years they'll retire
at age 62 and then they will enjoy the
last 10 to 15 years of their life that
sounds like a pretty bad life to me
actually what he's doing is he's living
his life as he goes so he worked hard
sold some companies got some cash put it
into bitcoin and now he's traveling
around with his wife and his daughters
or three kids and uh they're having a
time of their life there's photos all
over the internet of them doing all
kinds of cool dope stuff and when you
think about it they're not just relying
on the bitcoin so he still has cash flow
from what we understand and he's still
able to kind of live off some of the
cash flow plus off of the savings but to
me this is the ultimate amount of
freedom is when you can acquire enough
wealth to be able to do whatever you
want if you want to sit at home on the
couch and watch television which nobody
does anymore but if you want to do that
you can do that if you want to go travel
around the world with your wife and kids
and kind of go to all these cool exotic
places you can do that as well but
freedom is the key and so while the rest
of folks are stuck on the fact that didi
tahutu ended up putting all of the uh
wealth into bitcoin
a lot of bitcoiners i know have done
that he's just choosing to live a cool
dope life and go all around so we got
this quote from him he said quote i
choose that my life is never boring and
to see life as an adventure sometimes in
life you take strange steps but they
mostly lead to the best things i took
many like these steps in my life and i
never regret them
dd just like the step i took of selling
all of our family belongings including
our companies in-house and then
investing it all in bitcoin this was a
shock to many people and still is it got
even stranger when we decided to share
our wealth with charities and now live a
decentral life solely on cryptocurrency
for more than three years now
like
this dope
yeah right like just just living life
enjoying themselves
yeah i like how you stress to his kids
that you don't need materialistic things
to uh be happy and have freedom and he's
obviously still has an income so it's
nothing uh detrimental to his lifestyle
if he ever wanted to go back to that but
it's just interesting what he's teaching
his kids well there's some people too
that like when they get to a certain
level uh we we don't know obviously how
much he uh the bitcoin how much bitcoin
he owns and how much it's appreciated
and all this stuff but there's some
people who are always chasing that next
thing right so you get a certain level
of wealth whether it's a million dollars
or a hundred million dollars and you
just keep stacking and you're like hey
look i want more i want more i want more
because they like winning right and they
like winning to the to the degree of
like we're going to keep going we're
going to keep going and they can't ever
slow down and figure out uh what they
want to do and realize hey look life's
short let's go have some fun and do all
these different things so i think it's
cool that uh he's using the money as a
means to freedom and not necessarily
doing uh extreme lavish all these crazy
things but more so to spend time with
his family to travel to do different
things and really enjoying uh one of his
high conviction bets that paid off
we have a second quote from where he
says quote i saw that more people
started to buy and talk about bitcoin so
i understood the monetary revolution was
starting my wife agreed that we were
very happy as traveling family that we
want that we needed to teach the kids
that they can be happy without all the
luxury we had at home so we decided to
sell our house and all of our other
belongings to support the revolution and
go all in bitcoin now one of the things
that is very important here that is
another takeaway from this uh years ago
somebody told me
one of if not the most important
decisions you will ever make in your
life is who your partner is right the
person that you choose to spend your
life with ends up having a material an
outsized impact on the things that you
do the financial decisions you make uh
the the jobs and the careers you pursue
the kids where you live all these
different things all these components of
your life that are important uh the
person that you end up actually spending
your life with has an outsized impact
and so that is one of the most important
decisions so when you see here he says
my wife agreed that we were very happy
as traveling family and that we needed
to teach the kids that they can be happy
without all the luxury we had at home
there is appears to at least be a
alignment of ethos and an alignment in
the way that they wanted to raise their
kids and so when you're able to do that
that leads to
usually not only a happier life but also
one that uh empowers both people in a
marriage to be much more prosperous and
so i think the takeaway here yes sure
they went they did all this bitcoin
stuff it's amazing cool everyone likes
to write about it uh but more
importantly is this way of living life
and really enjoying it and teaching your
kids something uh seems to be not the
norm but i actually think that guy
understands more about life and uh in
kind of business and finance and and uh
uh investing than most people do yeah i
was gonna say
i feel like the saying is common that
like most people just uh believe they
want to be happy and be free and not be
tied to certain things or locations or
jobs and all this kind of stuff but i
think when it comes down to it you don't
really decide or figure that out until
these people have money right and if you
give someone this kind of amount of
money usually uh typically they'll go
and they'll spend it on luxury goods
they'll go do certain things they'll
always chase more so i think it's cool
to see someone who's actually living
that ethos out of like hey look i just
want uh freedom i want the flexibility
to do whatever i want i'm optimizing for
fun and happiness with my family uh and
they're living it out now so i think
it's cool that um he's literally living
that every single day and it's not
something that everyone would do when
they're when they're provided that kind
of level of wealth
john what do you think about this would
you do this
what would you do if you if you had like
if i was just kidding you came to me one
day and said all our money is
decentralized and we're gonna start
moving around if you if you were him if
you sold three companies you had uh
enough money to do this would you do
this
yeah i mean look i want to stress he
still has an income right and some of
that income actually probably comes from
doing this right the ability to do if
he's a keynote speaker somewhere he
travels there and uh he talks about
bitcoin and all that one thing i want to
talk about is how he stores his bitcoin
all right what does he do i love how you
always stress and don't store it all in
one place he has 74 of it in cold
storage and 26 percent of it in hot
wallets so another long-term holder off
off he's spending it too right is that
he says he's all in on bitcoin does that
mean that he's using it for every
transaction too like what it i i don't
know the exact details of it uh we
outsourced the research of this to cnbc
uh and they take your problems up with
them yeah yeah yeah
about the reporting cnbc uh was
outsourced for our research team uh but
i believe that he spends some of it but
majority of it is just held in uh in
cold storage like 78 yeah well my point
was that he's got to hold some of it
right if he's going to be spending it
all he said he's got two spots in europe
two in asia one in south america and six
in australia where he keeps it do you
think he put it places where people know
like did he go to uh his boy and he's
like yeah i'm gonna leave this here
don't hiding i don't know how he would
go to his boy hold on hiding spots
include rental apartments friends home
oh and store self storage sites so
basically his whole idea was he didn't
want to give it to to banks or anything
like that something that is centralized
could be shut down i'm not leaving my
wall with no friends nobody no rental
apartment hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it
you